she has left behind family and friends
in Greece now despina Panagiotopoulos
wants to make a new start in Germany for
the past few weeks she's been taking
part in a language scholarship in
Frankfurt a visit to the employment
office is part of the program in her
home country she presently has little
chance of finding work as a
mathematician the 23 year old spent the
past year sending out job applications
without success came and bought the many
no reply not even an email nothing
Nathan I don't know now she's getting
advice on how to apply properly in
German you should avoid cliched formulas
like I read your job posting with great
interest oh and then the right job will
hopefully come along Kelly and she's got
a degree but can't find work and here in
Germany we can't find people to fill our
jobs that's ideal it gives people like
her a chance to develop of course we
can't address our entire shortage of
skilled workers with one or even 18
people but it's a first step good the
Metzler foundation has brought 17 young
people to Germany
annoyed water they come from Greece
Portugal Spain and Italy they know a
little German after four months of
intensive language courses at the goethe
institute the young graduates will be
ready for the german labor market i can
make my room nicer by painting the walls
devender special they are engineers
computer scientists and biochemists and
all well educated now they'll finally
get the chance to work in their fields
the port officials Portuguese companies
always want experience but we don't have
any and no one will give us that
experience I said okay I'll try Germany
because Germany also has many companies
by the total metal feeler from the new
moon Ashley I may die soon I'm learning
German so I can have more opportunities
to find a job I name my first Atlas
offended my dream is to work here to
have a career and perhaps raise a family
here but the first step is to find your
way in a foreign country and that
includes more than good German
how do you open a bank account how do
you find an apartment to answer the many
questions that every newcomer has
participants are assigned someone to
help them if we did I say Jim game for
me he's fine negative yanling is a good
friend to me she's like a godmother and
a big help in solving daily problems
problem top oh I had more or less the
same experiences when I came to Germany
it was all foreign to me and all I'd
learnt was the language the idea for the
program came about here at the Metzler
banking house in the middle of
frankfurt's financial district the bank
has been around since 1674 and it is
still in family hands today it's headed
by free Trish phone Metzler in the 11th
generation and just like his ancestors
he's keen to take on social
responsibility the scholarship program
is part of this does is Dinah talked to
Joe this is practical European help for
young people they gain professional
experience they're no longer just
graduates they can go on to help their
countries later either by working there
or by working here in beta and mg albino
day off i phone Metzler is always
looking for more sponsors a scholarship
costs ten thousand euros there are 17
people in the second year's group almost
all graduates of the first year's group
found employment in Germany that's what
these young people want to yeah I'm on
funk
they in the beginning I want to work and
then maybe start on a master's degree if
I get this scholarship has another three
months to go then the young graduates
can start their working lives the new
applicants are waiting in the wings the
next scholarship program starts in the
autumn
you